more than 30 years have passed since the
release of the original child's play and
Chucky has remained in the public
consciousness ever since
but everything old must be new again and
the killer doll is finally stepping up
to the reboot plate what do you need to
know before seeing the new movie in the
first child's play movie from 1988 the
killer doll named Chucky starts out as a
humble murderer of the non doll variety
during the first two acts of his life
Chucky lived as Charles Lee ray
otherwise known as the lakeshore
strangler ray was a relatively
unremarkable crime enthusiast
distinguished by an interest in voodoo
in the opening scene ray is mortally
wounded by a police officer while
fleeing a robbery in a last act of
desperation he uses his voodoo expertise
to transfer his soul into a good guy
doll
the longer his consciousness stays
inside the doll the more attached he
becomes - it's creepy plastic form hi
I'm Chucky and I'm your friends at the
end though he'd spend the next three
decades waffling on whether he wanted to
remain a doll Ray's first couple of
adventures found him trying to put his
soul into another human body and
stabbing some revenge into anyone that
got in his way for the 2019 child's play
reboot the Voodoo angle seems to have
been scrapped this time around Chucky is
being presented as a Buddy doll an
animatronic smart toy for a new
generation of Facebook and iPhone users
according to paste director Lars clever
says he's an out-of-control robot doll
introducing your new best friend with
it's distasteful take on modern
technology the new child's play sounds
like it's going for a distinctly black
mirror kind of vibe Chuckie even uses
Wi-Fi connected smart devices like
drones to assist in much of the mayhem
it's certainly a departure from the
enchanted revenge toy we've all come to
know over the years whether fans of the
old movies will be on board with this
new Chucky remains to be seen in all
seven of the original Chucky movies the
killer doll was played by acclaimed
character actor Brad Dourif who also
portrays Wormtongue in the Lord of the
Rings movies and Doc Cochran on Deadwood
he made the funniest face when I dream
did you see this game when I sliced open
his guts
20-19 marks the first time a Chucky
movie hasn't used Dourif sauce instead
the studio enlisted Mark Hamill for the
job
beyond playing Luke Skywalker Hamill has
become one of the most successful voice
actors in Hollywood memorably voicing
the Joker on Batman the Animated Series
and here's where things start to get a
little bit meta he even played Charles
Lee ray on an episode of Robot Chicken
back in 2005
come on get some Brad Dourif voiced
Chucky in all seven of the original
films and creator Don Mancini wrote or
co-wrote every entry in the series
directing three of them producer David
Kirchner was also involved in all of the
films but eagle-eyed viewers will notice
that not one of these names appears in
the credits for 2019 child's play what's
the deal with that
as it turns out the reboot is happening
against the wishes of the original
creators of child's play
Mancini even requested that his name not
be included in the film's credits in a
2018 interview with the post mortem
podcast he described how difficult it
was to keep the franchise going for 30
years only to have it pulled out from
under him obviously my feelings were
hurt the ill will reportedly runs much
deeper than that
jennifer Tilly the titular Bride of
Chucky even started a not my Chucky
campaign on Twitter for fans of the
original child's play franchise there's
still good news due to some legal
loopholes the rights to Chucky are
astonishingly murky as a result Mancini
plans to continue his Chucky stories in
a TV series in the near future
Chucky has gone through a number of
changes over the years but there's one
thing that's certainly been consistent
throughout the films when the cameras
start rolling animatronics are the star
of the show
naturally when word got out that a
reboot was in the works fans were
nervous at the prospect of an all CGI
murder doll trying to take the place of
their beloved psychotic puppet good news
for the purists the new child's play
production reportedly uses a total of
six animatronic Chucky dolls operated by
three to four puppeteers at a time in a
behind-the-scenes video producer David
Katzenberg said details about the new
movie are pretty slim right now by all
accounts child's play is a
straightforward horror flick without a
whole lot of room for comedy that said
if things do get weird it'd be far from
a first for Chucky well the first three
child's play movies were fairly straight
faced thrillers Bride of Chucky came
along in 1998 and took the series in a
campy new direction things got
increasingly bizarre from there
that same year Chucky appeared on
Saturday Night Live's Weekend Update
segment with Colin Quinn well I think I
speak for most Americans when I say
enough already
Chucky also quite memorably high
jacked a WCW wrestling broadcast and
then there was that interview with
Entertainment Weekly really want to know
if I have a tickle me function push here
dipstick and see what happened most
recently he made a highly memorable
cameo in 2018 s ready player one the
point is the strangest thing would be if
the new Chucky didn't get strange check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite films are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]